comment lutter contre les ingérences
numérique à quelques mois des élections
présidentielles le gouvernement vient de
lancer une agence spécialisée son nom
vigie nomme objectif surveiller les
réseaux sociaux à la recherche de fake
news de faire battre hall ou de
tentatives de piratage l' agence
permettra ainsi d'éviter toute
perturbation lors du prochain scrutin
présidentiel comme ce fut le cas en 2017
avec le piratage des boîtes mails de la
campagne des manuels macron le
dispositif sera testé en décembre
prochain pour le référendum sur
l'indépendance nouvelle calédonie un
outil dont l'efficacité reste à prouver
selon ti rival avocat au barreau de
paris
moi je resterai très circonspect par
rapport à l'efficacité de ce type de
deux mesures on l'a vu d'ailleurs en
2019 lors d'un scrutin précédent il n'y
avait eu qu'une seule une seule action
qui avait été qui avait été menée sur la
manipulation de l'information et donc et
qui avait fait chou blanc s'est
d'ailleurs une facture de 2,2 du
ministre castaner qui avait été à
l'origine donc voila c'était papa très
pas très glorieux moi je ne pense pas
forcément que ça soit un outil qui qui
aura énormément de d'influx ans par
rapport à par rapport au fait que news
qui sont beaucoup plus faciles et
rapides à intervenir qu'ensuite les
divulguer